all right I am going live for a little
bit tonight hopefully the sound is
coming in nice and clean because you
notice a new microphone here that's
that's yeah I was shooting some videos
for my online ethics for artists and
designers class using the new mic and I
thought maybe I'll go on and shoot some
or do do some live feed stuff right now
so it looks like we've got a few people
in here already
some people are rather excited I just
managed to get the postings up very
quickly so let me tell you about the the
microphone and then I'll answer some
questions or look at comments and stuff
like that you know you'll notice that if
you've seen in my other used to use this
blue snowball and that has been crapping
out to the point where I couldn't get
consistent sound out of it and it was
echoing and doing weird stuff and then a
buzz involved so you know I talked to my
wife and I was like listen we got to get
a new new microphone so we did a little
bit of research and settled on this same
blue company but a better you know
closer to professional standards Yeti
which looks like it'll be kind of nice
so I don't have anything particularly
planned for this but I just wanted to
try it out I'm still playing around with
settings it's got more possible settings
than just the three in the back that
this thing had so let me take a look at
what we've got here in the hopper as far
as questions I have to click a few
actually let them get shown Cesar asked
what's my favourite piece of literature
in in philosophy and I guess you know
you could say that philosophy forth if
we're understanding literature in the
broad sense that philosophy is a kind of
right at least written philosophy I mean
the Platonic dialogues are really quite
great and there are other people who
wrote dialogues as well like Anselm of
Canterbury dialogues are really good
Augustine's are you know pretty good as
well I I kind of liked them Hume is is
somebody who I think people know in part
for his dialogues on natural religion
and there are quite a few people who
wrote dialogues many of which we've lost
so the dialogue form is kind of a cool
way of doing things when it's not just
using the dialogue to essentially be a
monologue even Plato falls into that
every once in a while where it's just
Glaucon saying yes Socrates so brilliant
Socrates I understand Socrates but when
there's actual like clashes between them
then it's quite good and you know
philosophical literature whether it's
Dostoevsky who was a master at this I
think the book that he's best in with
that is the possessed or the demons
depending on how you translate it but
brothers karmas office is great for that
as well and even the idiot or you know
think about the the stories of philip k
dick or somebody who i read recently our
scott backer they're taking you know
philosophical ideas and putting them
into dialogue form what's cool about
dialogues is that if the characters
matter the characters in some way
exemplify or show what the positions
that they're taking actually amount to
all right so let me see what else we got
here henry asks do I have plans to
expand the Kierkegaard series I've read
through a number of his works and I feel
like I've barely scratched the surface
well I don't have a Kierkegaard series I
was doing Kierkegaard as part of the
existentialism series which I will I
guess down the line start up again once
I'm not quite so busy that was our long
lectures and yeah I'd like to do
sickness on to death definitely and
probably
repetition I don't know if I want to do
either work is such a big book and
there's other things too you know works
of love is worth checking out but you
know I'll probably get get into it
eventually anthony thicker es do you
have any thoughts on jean-luc Mari owned
yeah I've actually met him and when I
did meet him he was kind of a jerk he
came down to Southern Illinois
University and you know because Tony
Steinbach was there who I did my
master's thesis under and and Steinbach
was a big phenomenology guy although
he's he's really somebody who's whose
star crested very early and is kind of
you know went into decline after that
but you know kind of a name is a host or
else call her and Mariana is interested
in who's real as well and so so Mario
came and I was you know sort of working
on my dissertation at the time but I got
invited to go to like his talk and and
lunch with him and all that and I spoke
French and and I was in that weird sort
of what's your status thing between like
being a graduate student and being a
professor so they seated me close to him
as a matter of fact I was sitting right
next to him because he really didn't
want to talk English much he just wanted
to talk French and so you know I was
trying we were talking back and forth
and all these poor graduate students
were sitting around at this expensive
restaurant and after a while I was like
you know they're here to ask you
questions that they didn't go here just
to have lunch and I don't remember
exactly what he said and I was like do
you think you could add you know like
answer some of their questions and he
said something along the lines of you
know if they were if they were important
I would and for me there was that and
then of course I asked him where in
France he was from and he looked at me
like I was an idiot and he was like
Paris where else you know and I was like
you know that that whole there's this
whole like Paris versus everybody else
thing in in France and and I'm kind of
hip to that
and you know it's sort of like with us
in America with New Yorkers or
Washington DC you know and so he did not
in his the way conducted himself really
live up to all this talk about charity
and the other top that I've been told
that he's behaved differently you know
in more recent times but you know I kind
of think that you walk the walk if
you're gonna talk the talk so if you're
gonna make charity you know you're
absolutely central concept
you better exemplify that when you're
dealing with people who are in a lower
power position than you so that's my
those are my thoughts on a child look
Mario I also interacted with him when he
when he was doing stuff of the lumen
christi institute and i was still living
in the Chicagoland area
so all right let's see here Tony Mueller
do you think Derrida is haunt all Egeus
masturbatory I guess if we mean by
masturbatory that there's a lot of you
know sort of playing with yourself and
not engaging
you know Derrida engages a lot of other
thinkers but he does so in a way that
sort of it's it's all centered around
what dairy does interested in you don't
you don't get the sense in a lot of his
writings with the exception of the early
stuff and and some of the later stuff
but you don't get the sense that he's
really trying to understand say
Descartes for you know on Descartes zone
grounds or something like that and you
can do that and still think somebody's
wrong somebody who I would say is really
good at that as Alistair McIntyre you
know so you can do this this sort of
engaged critique of a thinker that's not
just playing around with them and
showing how clever you are and and you
know Derrida sometimes has really great
things to say but a lot of what he is
doing is just sort of cleverness and I
think you know is again I'll tell you
another story about my graduate school
so I was at a conference
was actually expect the Society for
phenomenological and existential
philosophy and I had actually thought
about doing my dissertation on dairy
down and I was there with my friend Phil
Dean and he introduced me to a friend of
his from I don't know some someplace out
east like Yale or something kind of a
big-name place and she was like at the
same stage in her her studies as we were
we were all working on dissertations and
she started and and she was doing her
dissertation on dear dad she started
talking about you know all this you know
what's she doing and and you know what's
the topic and all that and I thought was
really cool you know this will be fun
we can talk about that Phil's gonna be a
little bit out to sea cuz he's more of a
dewey guy but you know it'll be fine
Phil Phil's a cool guy and she just
talked and it was all this like it was
like just straight jargon and I didn't
even back then I was rather you know
assertive when it came to like calling
people on stuff but I was like listening
to her and I was like I don't think she
actually knows what a lot of these terms
mean and then I realized that Derrida
was somebody you could do that with
quite easily there's just all this stuff
all this jargon all this you know fun
cool stuff to play with but you don't
know whether whether all of it is
[ __ ] or not unless you like think
your way all the way through it that's
one of the big problems by the way it's
jejak to you you got expend so much work
figuring out just what is actually being
said that some of it may not be actually
worthwhile spending the time on so and
you know you can say that about you can
say that about continental philosophy in
general you can also say that about
analytic philosophy in general too when
you figure out what they mean by this
ISM or this problem that their their
labeling you're like this is kind of
trivial [ __ ] you know there went a
couple hours or a couple days or
whatever you devoted to it you kind of
like to get some some return on
investment you could say all right when
it comes to studying philosophy you
kind of like if you're gonna invest the
time to you know read through des cartes
meditations and really think about it
you kind of like to know that you're
gonna get something out of it not
necessarily that it'll all be true but
that there'll be a system there that you
can understand or a set of concepts that
you can use somewhere right and too much
of the too much of analytic and
continental philosophy just doesn't
doesn't provide that to us all right
Abdul says how's the new year's
resolution going I didn't make any new
year's resolutions you know I think that
it's better if you don't make
resolutions but instead you you do other
things you know like set goals or things
like that I mean I've been going to the
gym and that's good you know we're
eating pretty healthy I just made a made
almost six quarts of good chili today
using some of the stuff that we had on
hand and you know not getting as much
video work done as I'd like but what I
said ever the case that I do you know so
alright let's see what else we got
here's a lot a lot of stuff human
evolution asks our externals necessary
for good life if this does does this fly
in the face of stoicism and falsify one
of its core concepts no it doesn't as a
matter of fact you want to read Cicero's
on the ends clarifies that right up read
book three and then read book four yeah
externals are necessary for the good
life they're not necessary in the same
way that the good is necessary for the
good life but you know managing
externals properly as part of virtue for
the Stoics that's one one place where
the Stoics are different than say the
cynics this is kind of a basic point and
again if you read epictetus you'll
you'll get that to read beyond there's
things in our power not in our power and
find out what what he actually says
about
the things that aren't in our power the
externals how we use them is in our
power so yeah that's a straight one
happy 63 funny platini's version of evil
versus Plato I don't know the Plato has
a version of evil right does he he
discusses the the bad at a number of
points and you know I would say that
that you know where Plato is really
following Socrates he thinks that there
is there is evil but that human beings
engage in evil out of out of ignorance a
mafia this is something the Stoics took
from Socrates as well
I mean plutinos tends to associate it
with you know this emanation of whatever
we want to call it the one through all
these these these things into ultimately
matter but you know it's not evil in the
same sense as we might evils kind of an
equivocal term we got to be we got to be
a little bit careful with it
Zeno what is a good introduction to
post-modernism I've only read the
fiction side of post-modernism not the
philosophy side I don't know that
there's a good introduction to it I
would actually be quite leery of
anything that pretends to be an
introduction to it because it's a
complex concept and you know I usually
recommend reading Jameson's
post-modernism the cultural logic of
late capitalism that's a book about this
thick all sorts of literary allusions
that you'll have to like work your way
through I mean you could read Lee
shorter leotards postmodern condition
you might want to like look at the the
work where the term gets essentially
coined but I don't know you know I don't
really read a lot of introductory
literature except this stuff that people
send me for reviews so a payroll by the
payroll by is that's you know and what
are important works in the philosophy of
math
I don't know it's not I mean not really
my area I mean I read like cantor and
you know read guru dal and people like
that back when I was studying math long
with philosophy of course we can Oh back
then it was the 90s so everybody read
girdle Escher Bach bye-bye Hofstadter
and it's quite good but I don't I don't
know who the the important works are in
the philosophy of mathematics quite
frankly I don't really do a lot of that
that work boarded our rights Sir Roger
Scruton passed away two weeks ago there
was more recent than that wasn't it yeah
people pass away I'm not I'm not
somebody who was particularly invested
in Scruton you haven't read a lot of his
stuff and you know I know about him
mostly through through you know the
debates about him on Twitter so you know
I guess if he was like oh sháá then he
might be somebody interesting for me to
read because I like oak shots version of
you know understanding what
conservativism means but I don't really
know where Scruton was with it so yeah
it's enough to like stay on top of the
people who call themselves conservatives
over here right original Bon Jovi how it
interest in human phenomena probably
backing up the difference between
reality and appearance
you know Aristotle has that category of
the certainly when it comes to goods the
apparent good versus the actual good and
I don't think he'd have any any real
difficulty with that Kant is asserting
that you know we can't no numa no you
know like hi you can only think it in a
certain way but we have just limits
there I think it's perfectly fine for an
Aristotelian to say yeah I don't buy a
can't I don't go down that path with you
so yeah Nate what do you think is the
main difference between continental and
analytic philosophy I don't think there
is a main difference I think there's a
body or bundle oh it says and some of
them have to do a style but I mean so
much difference in style in different
different branches of continental
philosophy then you can't just say oh
well they're more oriented toward tax or
they write in a more convoluted style
and analytics are always clear I mean if
you read enough analytic philosophy that
the whole like clarity thing will go out
the window you'll be like this [ __ ] is
not all that clear sometimes it is
sometimes it isn't and I think it's
better to look at it is like - it's
almost like you know what's the
difference between Republicans and
conservatives well there's there's some
key issues but a lot of it has to do
with the coalition's that they represent
right and then they become sort of like
part of a discourse and I think I think
that's that's become the case with
analytic and continental philosophy you
know I also think too that the analytic
continental divide has dominated far too
much brain space because it's
essentially like saying you know all of
philosophy is either Indonesian or
Filipino well oh that's not even all of
that area all right you've also got
Thailand and China and Australia all
right and you know talking about the
analytic continental thing they're
they're both too parochial camps that
have a fairly recent provenance that
only goes back like you know century for
analytics well century in a couple
decades and maybe two centuries for
Continentals at best and there's many
other you know strains of philosophy out
there that are equally interesting and
equally important it just so happens
that the American
academy and largely the british academy
is dominated by one of those two but I
think you probably want to get away from
from that Dimitri what's your favorite
children's literature that's a good
question I mean I don't read a lot of
children's literature I used to read by
my kid my daughter when you know she was
quite young I'd read her Grimm's fairy
tales because I quite like those both in
the German and in the English you know I
mean there was CS Lewis of course had
the great Narnia stuff and we did in the
worlds of speculative fiction we did do
the wrinkle and time series by Madeleine
L'Engle and those are those are pretty
good those hold up I don't know I don't
read a lot of kids literature these days
so I don't know Thomas yes see these
mics and a lot of YouTube videos what's
what sort of price range I think they go
they're like a hundred one hundred fifty
bucks but I think we also found it on
sale or something like that so it's you
know this is what patreon helps out with
right we turn that money into new
equipment and and you know stuff
eventually breaks down you know cameras
break down somehow my kids lost one of
my spare batteries for the camera I'm
sure there are the ones who probably
screwed up my old microphone knocking
and over it stuff like that but you know
that's that's that's just what life is
kaijin asks what is law philosophy can a
lawyer have a Doctorate degree to hire
his education yeah you know there are
some programs there's not a lot of them
out there but there's there are some
programs that are like a joint degree
where you get your JD your doctor doctor
of law right then you also get like a
PhD in philosophy I think if I remember
right I think that Indiana
university-purdue that that joint campus
that they have like down in Indy I think
they may have had a degree program like
that years back there's nothing to
prevent anybody who's got a degree in
one thing from getting a degree in
another thing so like you could have a
law degree and decide man it'd be useful
to have a master's in sociology so when
I'm making claims about you know the
stuff that I'm litigating I actually
understand like what's happening in this
city here or you know policing dynamics
or things like that and you could do
that with a philosophy degree I suppose
or you know to really stretch it out you
could have a law degree and you could go
get an MFA if you wanted to nobody's
gonna stop you guys I don't think but
you you probably won't be practicing
lawful time while you're doing that so
alright we would doctors say either do
you have a favorite painter if so I and
what's your favorite thing but I don't
have a favorite painter I will said you
have a favorite painting and it hangs
Pierre in the Milwaukee Art Museum it's
a massive thing by Anselm Kiefer called
midgard and you can you can look it up
online they have it you know they show
it on the museum website pretty cool I
like when I go in there every time that
I go and I haven't been there for a
couple of years even though we only live
a mile and a half from that's we're just
so busy every time I go in I try to
spend at least you know twenty to thirty
minutes with that painting and you can
very easily because its massive it's
it's like the see that that big window
behind me it's like the size of that
that massive window so alright
a couple of comments here CSS do I find
any value integrating your shadow like
young talks about or do you prefer
virtue ethics and suppressing passions
well that's a weird dichotomy that
you've got there I mean as if you know
Young is the only person who ever talked
about looking at and integrating the the
parts of yourself that you find shameful
or problematic
I mean virtue ethics if you read through
classic virtue ethics it's not all about
suppressing emotions or passions or
stuff like that yeah you can't suppress
them effectively unless you actually
understand yourself so you got to figure
out you know if we want to be quite
blunt you got to figure out what kind of
[ __ ] up you are and how you're [ __ ] up
in order to make any progress because
just you know like let's say you get
angry all the time all right I'm just
saying I'm not going to get angry like
like you in that Seinfeld episode
remember where George gets the verse
serenity now and by the end he's like
saying it through gritted teeth and then
blowing up at people that's not that's
not an actual virtue ethics approach a
virtue ethics approach it's a pro
supposed to provide you with ways of
analyzing things and psychotherapy and
depth psychology can be useful for that
I'm not a big buyer in of young I don't
really I like reading him but I like
reading him less about his own stuff and
more in his like quite witty discussions
of other people's stuff and I typically
don't get much out of young'uns in part
because they they tend to be you know I
just sort of regurgitating his his stuff
and and I mean even somebody like like
ha ooh I do like who's a Freudian I
probably only buy into a quarter of what
he says and then the rest I'm like yeah
I think this is [ __ ] so you know but
then there's there's stuff that that's
quite quite useful that we can do but
you know I wouldn't I wouldn't oppose
yogi and integrating the shadow to
virtue ethics suppressing emotions all
right to do this had [ __ ] I'm a pari
I'm a Parisian and I dab on peasants
well you're probably a dick that my mom
actually did get called a peasant when
the last time that she was over and in
Paris because she had a french-canadian
accent which is you know closely related
to what what people used to speak you
know sort of older French just like
Appalachian English is you know it's not
just like it didn't just generate its
its preserving older stuff and yeah
Parisians tend to think that the world
revolves around them and that they're
the best at everything and you know they
they do get the best opportunities
because things are so centralized in
France and everybody else can you know
from the Parisian perspective kind of
suck it very similar to how New Yorkers
view things and very similar to how the
people within the Beltway view things
and I'll tell you I have zero sympathy
for those those people and you know
their elitism so you won't find me agree
with you on that
Mourdock thoughts on analytic philosophy
of religion and natural theology it
might be divisive but it's super
important do you plan on talking more
about that kind of subject I find
analytic philosophy of religion very
boring and usually kind of missing the
point and tendentious usually analytics
are not very well grounded in any sort
of like historical tradition and I think
if you know if you're gonna try to do
anything that's going to do justice to
theology you better actually know a lot
of theology and not just like about
Molen is OMERS or some some nonsense
like that or do
hiddenness whatever the topic du jour is
you need to actually have read your way
you know if you're gonna talk about
Christianity you probably need to have
read your way through a lot of the
important authors you know from the
church fathers up to people like Pascal
or you're gonna be reinventing a lot of
wheels you know I I don't find analytic
philosophy of religion all that
interesting except for you know people
like John wisdom who of course read
other people you know outside of
analytic philosophy so you know the
stuff about about language that came out
of the you know MIT contingent things is
kind of interesting but they
unfortunately generally didn't take into
account all the stuff that was going on
that had to do with language and signs
going all the way back into the
patristic s-- you know and and in in
continental philosophy of religion so
you know I I don't if you if you say
it's super important that's great I
don't find it super important myself
will I talk more about that kind of
thing if I do a philosophy of religion
sequence or a class probably but it's
not the stuff that I find particularly
interesting all right Volkl Locke is it
possible to combine stoicism with an
absurdist view of the world reality how
fundamental is the belief in God God's
divine providence higher plan and
stoicism I would say that I mean you can
you can combine modern stoicism with non
you know a non-theistic non providential
way of looking at things
I don't know that absurdism is the one
way to go with that and it depends on
what sort of absurdism you're talking
about if you're talking about you know
Albert Camus I think there's prospects
there I think you know with most
things when you're combining them you're
gonna get to some points where you got
to say listen either A or B I can't have
both and I think that'll you know
that'll happen with stoicism and you
know cow Moos philosophy of the absurd
if you're talking about other people who
are you know in some ways much more just
like random and you know they'd call
whatever they're doing certain ism
stoicism is about rationality you know
and so there's a lot of ear rationalism
in a lot of people's absurdism and i
think that's what turned a lot of people
off on it you know from like the 60s 70s
onward just like you know in the
eighties there were all these people are
like yeah me and I'm doing Zen maybe
like get what the hell are you talking
about
you're just doing random [ __ ] in a bar
you know you're calling that Zen and
they'd be like yeah you know I learned a
little bit about it and and you'd be
like man you don't know anything about
Buddhism let alone Zen Buddhism
you know you how often are you
meditating and so I think you can say
something similar about stoicism you
know stoicism involves actual practices
now that you couldn't do that you know
from a cow Moos Ian's perspective but
you know it's it's a philosophy as a way
of life so yeah all right what do I
think about Alex Dugan I haven't
actually read him so you know from what
I've heard doesn't sound particularly
interesting because the
neo-traditionalist stuff usually winds
up being the same old kind of kind of
stuff you know I cut my teeth way back
in the day when I was doing a lot of
work on blown dal in 20th century
Catholic thought on you know reading sha
Mara and axial process and you know sort
of spiraling out and all these integral
nationalisms I'm willing to bet that I
would find that
a lot of what's gonna be in Dugan is
gonna be kind of similar I don't know
though I haven't haven't actually read
them so mm-hmm
I go waffles thoughts on Nikolas of
Kooser Duns Scotus both interesting
thinkers both people that I don't get
much time to look at Scott assailant
looked at for a long time
Nikolas of Kooza every once in a while
I'll open up stuff and take a look
around but I haven't done any serious
study of him for a long time either both
you know well worth reading and thinking
about but both people that I I haven't
made the time to spend any time with
recently and I never read that much of
SCOTUS you know it was just to like see
what was there and yeah it was a long
time ago all right so yes I feel like
phenomenology is 90% Wow I can just live
life bro you're probably running into
the wrong kind of people you know maybe
it's sort of like those people who are
saying I'm doing Zen man
there's people say they're doing
phenomenology but you know don't know
anything about classical phenomenology
so I don't know Zeno asked the meaning
of life with a colon I'm not sure what
that's supposed to be Maxwell Thomson
Kurtz do you personally think your
behavior would change if you didn't
believe in God no not all that much in
part because my behavior even though I
am a a believer in God is not
particularly driven by my my belief in
God so you know I'm not a particularly
devout or or following you know what I'm
supposed to be doing and moral life kind
of kind of person in that respect anyway
i fall fall quite short so in a trivial
sense not believing in God
wouldn't do all that much and I think
it's perfect I think people can have you
know a pretty good life and pretty good
motive behavior of leaving and that I
know plenty of atheists who are much
better people ethically speaking than
many of the Christians that I
self-identified Christians that I know I
mean we're living in a time when when
there's a lot of people who I mean it's
never not been this the case there's a
lot of people who are just hypocrites
right or or identify with something and
it's essentially just group membership
but they don't they don't really believe
it because they behave in a different
way right and it's very glaring right
now seeing like people lining up you
know in their politics with with
movements and people that are definitely
out of sync with with whatever values
they have right so no I don't think it
would make a huge difference
Mickey awesome what do I think of
Schaller and Carole vote EAA's
personalism and I read anything about
that
what about Edith Stein yeah as a matter
of fact I really like mock Schaller I
actually at one point in time translated
one of his works that hadn't been
translated friend of mine actually
published his version of the translation
many years later but he consulted mine
is when he was when he was going through
his and I think Schaller is really quite
good I think he's just as good as
Heidegger and I think both of them are
better than Husserl phenomenology let me
say this phenomenology understood it's
sort of a branch of continental
philosophy produced for itself a lineage
in genealogy that was rather
exclusionary and
worked very well for the people who are
kind of in the know right who could who
could claim to sentence threat and it
ran like brentano who nobody would read
Horrell who then became very important
Heidegger loving us merleau-ponty
Derrida Mario blah blah blah blah blah
right with Michele honoree in there as
well and a few other people that might
get like honorary mention and then
Schaller was construed as like well he
was kind of like a student knew his role
I think or stuff like that it was
complete [ __ ] you know Schaller was
doing his own thing phenomenology was
not something like owned by hoarser all
right it was it was a thing that was
going on across the board blown down
Maurice Blondell was doing phenomenology
he just called it the philosophy of
imminence Bergson was doing
phenomenology called that the attention
to the immediate data of life
Gabrielle Marcel was doing phenomenology
early on as well and so Schuyler is is
really one of the the big figures in in
early phenomenology and he's he's doing
a phenomenology that's centered around
value so I think that his work is
particularly good I also think eated
Stein is is quite good too although
she's more limited than Schaller is and
voltea you know who later becomes John
John Paul the second
he's quite good I've read I've read the
translation of the acting person people
say that it's not a very good
translation
I don't know cuz i don't read polish
right but that whole like Lublin tome
ISM thing was kind of a cool thing and I
think that there's all sorts of really
interesting figures in the
phenomenological movement that are
highly underrated in philosophy of
religion john herring for example
spelled like herring right but
pronounced earring and you know somebody
else I'll mention who was a student of
course roll that some people might find
interesting
Roman in garden his work is really
friggin boring though but you can say
the same thing about Husserl's analyses
as well and then you know from Heidegger
we get this whole you know sort of
hermeneutic thing with goddamn err
there's also Recor doing stuff on
phenomenology in France who by the way
was was also involved in a the Christian
philosophy debate so there were all
these interesting figures and so many of
them have unfortunately been ignored and
sidelined because they didn't fit into a
neat narrative that the people who teach
continental philosophy were invested in
so Riverside library did you ever do
psychedelics if so what and how much I
only did I never did any psychedelics as
such you know like acid or mushrooms or
that sort of thing as a matter of fact
you know when it comes to drugs I
haven't done much at all I prefer to
drink you know I enjoyed alcohol much
more than than anything else that I
tried smoked some pot when I was in
graduate school but I didn't like pot
heads because they they were content to
sit around and do nothing all day and
just laugh at at stuff you know and I
found that really quite boring and the
only other things that I ever tried and
I tried them well you know I was the
drunk and smoking marijuana would be
ecstasy and PCP and the ecstasy I tried
just once I had this this German
girlfriend who was you know kind of a
beau not kind of she was a heavy pothead
yeah she was such a great pothead that
she would roll these gigantic joints
that would take like five papers and
have a filter earth yet like ash in the
middle and people would give her stuff
just to have her roll joints and so she
was also into all sorts of other things
she was like a big techno
at the time - so you know she she had us
each doing ecstasy but I don't I don't
know if it was any good because you know
I was drunk at the time and and we were
smoking smoking pot and then I I had a
cousin who was selling pot who laced the
pot that he had us smoked that time and
as a matter of fact that girlfriend was
there too and he laced it with PCP and I
did not like that holy crap I would
never do that again
so yeah there there we go I'm not I'm
not a big believer in the like opening
the doors of consciousness kind of thing
I I think that a lot of that's really
just [ __ ] and I think that you know
if you can use it for that sort of thing
it's sort of like you know what what the
spiritual masters were were telling
Hawksley when he was writing about that
sort of stuff they're like you know you
should do meditation instead but you
know people people like that sort of
thing I think you know they see it as a
sort of there's a sort of mystique
involved with psychedelics just never
been attracted to that sort of thing
let's see here the neo epicurean thanks
for the videos I've watched a lot I just
wrote an essay on Achrafieh
watch your weakness of will video many
times oh that's good yeah that's that's
something really quite important you
know I don't trust priests most of them
get caught touching kids so much for a
higher morality well you know that's
stupid [ __ ] right most of them don't
get don't get caught touching kids the
rate of sexual abuse among Catholic
priests is no higher than it is for
social workers police officers you know
ministers of Pentecostal churches rabbis
pick whatever you like anybody who's got
unsupervised contact with kids there's a
tendency for there to be problems and it
doesn't have anything
do with with religion in particular
that's just a noxious stereotype that
people have I don't you know there's a
lot of priests that I don't trust
because I think they're not very good
priests same thing with bishops I think
the bishops are particularly sorry a lot
at this point in time you know but you
can say similarly of CEOs can't you so
alright Laius asked whoops just jumped
there was a question here about sex TISS
empirica there's a lot of questions here
I'm on my side I see like you know only
a portion of what's being asked until it
suddenly skips down all right man I'm
scrolling up a lot and still here we go
do I have any plans on making videos on
sexist empirica yeah actually I would
like to do that it's a question of
finding the time that would probably
have to happen in the summer and the
fall because right now I'm shooting a
lot of core concept videos for the
classes that I'm currently teaching and
so there's a lot of content I need to
you know crank out but yeah that is a
big gap I'd also like to shoot some
stuff on the cynics you know more stuff
on the Epicureans like I'm Lucretius so
alright Ben asks do I think it's
worthwhile for someone to go and study
philosophy at University at 30 if they
want a career afterwards it depends on
what kind of career do you want to try
to teach philosophy as a full-time
employed professor those jobs are fewer
and fewer every year and they tend to
get they tend to get taken up by the
people coming from the elite
universities so people who are coming
from anything less than the elite are
having an incredibly hard time finding
full-time work and I mean you could you
could adjunct but adjunct is
only good if you've got another thing on
the side so like you know I've got I add
junk but I've got my business so that
you know I'm not making a ton of money
teaching at Marquette or Milwaukee
Institute of Art and Design and I'm not
getting any benefits from them as a
matter of fact I know we're on the
affordable care act marketplaces because
we're self-employed but you know I have
my business so if that's your sort of
thing that you plan to do that's that's
okay and you can you can do a lot of
things with a philosophy degree that
aren't being a philosophy professor so
you could go into all sorts of fields
some of which you might train for it
like you know let's say you wanted to be
a medical ethicist and work in a
hospital
that's something you'd specialize them
during your studies so they're there
there are quite a few things that you
can you can do with a degree so yeah um
let's see here Alexander says with my
course and Hegel you could he could
understand him I'm glad it helped you
then all right
the pink Arab what do I think of
veganism so I think that that veganism
as a whole is a good thing I think that
a lot of vegans are [ __ ] and I can't
stand spending time with them because
they're insufferable but that doesn't
really have to do that much with
veganism itself right I think I think
it's a good thing to you know I think
you know I think that the the the push
to like we got to be completely vegan
you know you can't even wear leather or
something like that and the cows dead
already
you know you're not gonna like put the
hide back on the cow by not wearing a
leather jacket I think though we can
reduce our use of animal products and
you know especially dairy and we can you
know certainly eat less meat and if
we're going to we can things can be
ethically farmed as we say in in you
know
sort of talking about ethical farming
the cow only has one bad day right and
in factory farming is horrific right so
there's there's certainly things to be
said for it being vegan doesn't mean
that you're not killing any animal life
I mean Peter Singer pointed this out he
you know when he came to the Culinary
Institute of America
people were asking him about agriculture
and he was like well you know when
you're when you're looking at you know
agriculture you are still killing things
living things not just plants but you
know the shrews and mice and the soil
and worms and stuff like that and so you
know I think it's it's important to be
realistic about it rather than
doctrinaire about it all right Joel said
all thoughts on Hegel's analysis of
Stoicism and the phenomenology I don't
think hey go got stoicism right
I think Hegel got a certain caricature
of stoicism right that that people
sometimes buy into even people today
claiming to be Stoics but I don't think
that for the most part he got it right
I've got a piece on that over and they
half-hour Hegel blog that you could you
could take a look at he has a little bit
more analysis of it in his history of
philosophy yeah here's an interesting
question
Lyn Oh Tex are you working on some
Magnus opus yourself as a philosopher
nope just trying to stay afloat keep up
with the work commitments that I've made
you know that's of my students to my
clients to the modern stoicism
organization as editor of stoicism today
to the people bringing in me and for
talks and stuff like that I maybe
there'll be a magnum opus someday but I
I don't know you know I I'm that's not
something that really matters that much
to me I'm I'm happy doing the kind of
stuff that I do I don't know that we
needed another magnum opus add a lot I'm
trying to read other people's mad
yeah Magne hope what is the what it's
the plural
yeah well marcos what do you think is
better Mir Aristotle well probably
Aristotle right I know him
so breezy free thoughts on the split
between Heidegger and Hegel regarding
Conte I don't know what the split
between Heidegger and Hegel would be
they're separated from each other by
more than a century
so all right Joseph Fowler what view do
you take at how des cartes code you
chose reached intuition or inference I
mean what does Descartes have to say on
that he doesn't think it's a intuition
which is a really vague term anyway he
reasons his way to the coach Ito so I
guess you'd say it's inference wouldn't
you what else could it be
ah Bruce is here thanks thanks Bruce
let's see what else we got here
Riverside library oh he's talking with
Zeno of Elea so I'm gonna skip over that
let me get rid of this stuff all right
Bruno says if philosophy is the product
of reason where a truth is found in
logic so I'll just stop you right there
that's that's not the case it why is it
there are so many different conflicting
schools of thought so I mean you started
with a non-starter
where truth is found in logic truth is
found in all sorts of modes it's not
just found in logic so that that
probably won't go anywhere why are there
different in conflicting schools of
thought because reality is complicated
and the human being is complicated
and so there's many different ways of
understanding things and that's that's
the reality that we have to work with in
terms of philosophy so Canal have a red
ear odd Kimmy's book I I don't even know
who Arad Kimi is so Diogenes asks what
do I think of Heidegger's concept of the
nothing and it's uncovering and anxiety
so I think Heidegger's understanding of
the nothing it's not a concept as such
but because it's it's not it's not that
kind of thing right enough he plays with
this lot that nothing nothing separates
the nothing from being etc etc
Heidegger's idea of it is not something
radically new but some of the things
that he's doing with it in terms of
human freedom are kind of new you know
freedom extends itself out into the
nothing and thereby adds something new
to being which is not a nothing but that
nothing is a condition for that and it
how does it revealed an anxiety or you
know oxd anguish it's also translated as
he talks about a receding of beings and
everything he's doing and in like you
know what his metaphysics or in his
discussions of this in being in time has
to be through metaphorical language but
I think we can we can relate to it and
it is I think it's a really good
analysis I don't think that anxiety is
the only truly revelatory mood the way
Heidegger made it out to be
somebody else who says that who's of
course got a much greater you know
output in pedigree than me as Adrian
pepper Zach who is that I think he's
retired now he was at Loyola he's got
some great books discussing these sorts
of things that he wrote in the early
2000s he was a phenomenologist worked on
lemme nasus worked on Heidegger worked
on on Hegel quite a I think he actually
studied under Recor if I remember right
- and
you know III tend to think that sorrow
and joy and awe can be as revelatory of
being as can anxiety I don't think that
anger can anger can be revelatory of a
lot but I don't think it can be
revelatory of being in the same way
here's a question by retro gamer when do
I think psych psychological analysis
and/or psyche analysis and typology will
integrate into moralist and ethical
metaphysical projects well I would say
that it'll do that when we have people
who are trained in in you know sort of
like bridging fields you know or like
translation problems you got to have
people who understand both and think
that they're both important and then
then they bring them together so that's
a and the other thing that that's a
factor there has to be there has to be
time there has to be institutional space
there has to be some sort of not
necessarily rewards but but something
that allows that activity to be
sustained but that's sort of a general
point about how do you bring together
you know something from column a and
something from column Q how do you do
that
generally so I think you know there are
there are people bringing things
together in interesting ways but I don't
know with those in particular alright so
I'm gonna have to get going pretty soon
actually get on with my work
but I'm going to answer just a few more
questions so I won't get to a lot of I
won't get to a lot of these but here's
one I should answer CS have you read any
big fiction tomes like James Joyce
Ulysses or David Foster Wallace's
Infinite Jest if you discern what
they're trying to get at I don't bother
with those sorts of things the high
literature I mean I do like some high
literature but I don't like Jane
and and people talked so much how great
Ulysses was and I read a bit of it and I
was like I'm not gonna waste my time on
this crap you know this is
self-indulgent stuff that just happens
to have a fanboy base that that keeps
saying it's a wonderful never even
cracked open Infinite Jest it there's
there's nothing that I've heard about it
that makes me think it's worth my time
that said you know I have spent time on
you know big fiction tomes there does
not those sorts of things you know there
are other there other tomes instead I'm
not I'm not into the you know high
modernist literature I have to say all
right um
to do to do let's see here oh here's a
good question from Gordon Ramsay have I
dabbled and pan psychism no it's it's
something that I'm seeing getting talked
about a lot on Twitter though and so
that's kind of interesting
I haven't devoted any time to it or any
study so there's there's not much for me
to say let me see what else I can
quickly answer before we get to the one
hour mark oh here's an interesting one
is this is a there's a more personal
question so I think this is good to go
out on see us when you were younger did
you imagine yourself having a kid or did
it just kind of happen and you were okay
with it
so I
three kids one miscarried and that was
with somebody who I was I was with as a
graduate student she was a librarian at
Southern Illinois University and we got
involved and in some respects we were
very compatible in other respects we we
weren't a good match but we were in love
with each other she got pregnant
and I think she was probably about four
months along
when you know things we'd had some some
tensions and she ended up miscarrying
and neither one of us have handled it
very well and we broke up but that would
have been my first kid and that was
unplanned
and but I was I was you know at that
time I would have been about 27 so I was
you know I was happy that that was that
was what was going on and then I got
married after my my mom died my adopted
mother and I had to handle her estate
and the person who I was involved with
at the time who turned out to be quite
different than I thought you know I was
not I was not all that that happy with
her but I you know I'd gotten to the
point where I was you know turning I was
in my going into my 30s and I thought
well you've really done a lot of you've
got a lot of you know pretty wild
affairs maybe it's time to like settle
down and all that and take on some adult
responsibilities you're gonna be
graduating you know fairly soon after
you get your dissertation finished and
I thought that getting married would
would change things but you know we were
neither one of us was in a very good
state to be married but we ended up
having kids and you know we divorced
afterwards and you know my kids who are
now you know my one is 17 and the others
12 there really there are good things
that came out of that that that
relationship been difficult to parent at
a distance and my my ex made it as
difficult as possible for quite a while
but you know you do what you can and my
relationship with my kids has grown and
changed and it's you know it's not as if
my relationship with them is just this
single thing it's also connected to my
relationship and their relationship with
my wife Andy who or you know her her
pets who have become you know my pets as
well or the people that were involved
with
and neither kid was was planned in the
sense of like oh now it's time to have
kids exactly but you know they were I
was open to it and I was happy to to
have kids some people don't really want
to be parents I you know I did and I do
and once you have kids if you take
parenting seriously your life will never
be the same
because you have these responsibilities
now that you bear towards other
developing people and you see you know
you get to see them going through some
of the same crap that you yourself went
through yeah
you know for example Maddie will do the
same sort of like making noises just to
make noise out of a sort of you know
like not even really thinking about it
that I used to do as a kid that drove my
mom and dad nuts and now it drives me
nuts you know and I have to remind
myself that that came from me
just as much as some of the things that
that I've got from from my own dad my
bio dad are you know part of my
temperaments and you know it's been
interesting to connecting up with my
biological father and my my siblings and
finding out not only how much we have in
common but also my kids have in common
with them too so to answer the question
you know I didn't do a lot of imagining
of myself having a kid once I did have
kids I imagine things like I would my
toes gonna you know I tried to teach
Catherine French and it just never stuck
you know we're gonna talk French at home
like my mom used to do with me and that
just didn't happen and we're you know
you imagine all these things you're
gonna do with them they're not into it
you know they're and and it makes sense
because they're not you you know they're
they're their own person who's
developing in the way that they do but
once you are a parent if you are a good
parents or even if you're I won't even
say I'm a good parent I'm somebody who
struggles to parent in the way that I
should
and takes it seriously your life is now
quite different you the things that you
do have have an impact you know part of
the reason why I'm I know I'm going way
over time I'm gonna have to get to work
three soon but you know part of why I'm
devoted to working out is I want to be
able to spend
another 40 years with my my kids I don't
want them to have the experience that I
had of losing my dad my adopted father
when he was 36 and I was 11 and losing
my adopted mother when I was 29 and she
was 53 I wanted to be there for all the
big things and I want to be able to give
them the advice that I couldn't get and
you know help them out in ways that you
know my mom tried to but but didn't
always succeed in so that's that's I
guess a good place to end on I've done
my share and you know like making sure
that we maintain the population to kids
who survived so far I will say one more
thing too once you have kids this goes
to like you know thinking about stoicism
and what's in your control and what's
not in your control you have made
yourself so much more vulnerable to the
world by having kids and caring about
them than you were before
but you can say similar things to about
like loving somebody in a relationship
now you've got other people that can get
hurt can can be bullied can encounter
prejudice or discrimination can make
stupid decisions of their own and you
you will be affected by it and there's
only so much that you can actually do to
to make it better or to stave off those
things you know but you're you're in it
so having children roots you in the
world and in a very new way so on that
I'm gonna end I didn't get to
everybody's questions and comments but I
never do so thanks for all of your
questions comments hope the mic sounds
good and I'm gonna leave off here